S.O.S. Retard bonjour ! Quel est votre numéro client ?
4225, s'il vous plaît
Bonjour monsieur Fichon,  sur quel type de retard on est?
C'est réunion, 30 minutes environ, s'il vous plaît.
Ok, c'est parti.
Je vous conseille de vous dépêcher un petit peu, monsieur Fichon.
Oui, bisous
Allez, dépêchez-vous, on va commencer.
Bon, on a pas mal de boulot.
Alors on va commencer par le dossier Choco-délire.
Qui commence?
Fichon?
Vas-y, fait le s'il-te-plait.
T'es trop con. T'es trop con. T'es trop con. T'es trop con.
Aie!
Qu'est-ce qu'il fout?
BON FICHON! On est pressé là!
*bruits de connection*
Alors, pour le dossier Chocodélire, je m'étais dit qu'on pourrais - pardon madame, excusez-moi pardon -
alors, on pourrais miser notre stratégie sur - euh
est-ce que vous pouvez ouvrir les portes s'il vous plait? -
on pourrais miser la stratégie sur ChocoCulcul
Le placement de la marque doit être subtile et fun
Donc si on concentre cette opération
sur notre mascot ChocoCulcul
Fichon?! Vous allez bien?
Ouais. Carrément. Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais.
Non, non, non, pas de soucis. - Aie putain -
Euh ChocoCulcul doit-être au
centre de notre opération
On peut vraiment montrer le côté délire et fun de Chocodélire.
Donc en gros, voila, tout ca pour dire qu'il faut
- oui, oui, oui, je vais au quatrième. Merci Madame -
Donc je pense vraiment un - putain mais barrez vous là -
je pense qu'il faut faire un call to action sur Facebook et Twitter en créant une page pour ChocoCulcul et...
Ah mais non, mais non, je suis
trop con, mais non mais non.
Mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce bordel Fichon?
Non, parce que en fait, c'est compliqué, c'est ...
- Qui êtes-vous monsieur?
Là vraiment, vraiment, je suis désolé mais...
Désolé, désolé, désolé.
- Excusez-moi, laissez moi passez.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ce bord..
Ecoutez, laissez nous travailler là.
En même temps, si on est toujours en retard...
Tu vois Thibaut, lui, il est toujours à l'heure et...
Et il est où Thibaut?